[Music]
locked solid
well no
i guess this isn't what you signed up
for when you decided to be a famous
actor is it it's not my fault i never
wanted to be famous
sorry kiddo that's not the way i
remember it
but i didn't want to be famous i wanted
to go to school
it's true
all of those people cheering and
applauding i hated it what's happening
jiminy
looks like some sort of fairy magic
kind of on the nose if you ask me but
the point is a lie can really change a
person pinocks which is why i'm telling
you the 110
most honestly honest truthiest
truthiness ever believe me
oops okay that last part wasn't true but
everything i sent up until then was
you okay more or less now quit telling
those whoppers
i see a lost soul an insect of no fixed
address an aimless vagabond hopping from
half to half with no direction no job no
prospects and no purpose in life now
look here just because a fellow sneaks
into somebody's house to warm his
backside and
sure he might have gotten kicked out of
a place or two but
okay you have point here's the thing do
you know the difference between right
and wrong you tootin i do i consider
myself a bug of high moral standards no
matter what you may have heard well that
settles it then
neil mr cricket
i hereby appoint you pinocchio's
conscience uh temporary conscience sure
temporary conscience until such time as
pinocchio may grow his own
henceforth you are the high keeper of
the knowledge of right and wrong and a
trusted counselor during moments of
temptation
[Music]
arise
so jiminy cricket
hey
this is more like it
[Music]
the idea of taking on a treasured
classic
as disney's pinocchio
it's an incredibly rich opportunity to
revisit and go deeper
into this great masterpiece
it's a wonderful journey
full of excitement
wonder
danger
everything is larger than life
taking on our story like pinocchio and
turning it into a live-action film is no
mean feat
pairing robert zemeckis with pinocchio a
sort of a match made in heaven
bob is one of these filmmakers it takes
you to places beyond your expectations
it's a really special story that
encourages people to wish and to dream
it has incredible songs we all will love
and remember it's just an honor to be
bringing it to a new generation
i think every audience wishes to be
transported that's the magic of cinema
great movies last forever and that's one
of the things that pinocchio delivers
[Music]
you'll all remember disney's pinocchio
the emotional beats the look on a face
a sequence of shots
and audiences carry it with them for the
rest of their days
seeing disney's pinocchio is one of my
earliest memories it was magnificent
i just remember being blown away by it
it was whimsical and otherworldly
pinocchio's been my favorite fairy tale
since i was a little kid there's
something special about his story this
new edition carries the torch of the
original
it's an honor to reimagine pinocchio
with new characters
[Music]
it's a brilliant story and an honor to
bring it to a new generation of children
adults who remember the original it's as
entertaining and as thrilling as it was
it reminds us that anything's possible
if you just believe
disney's pinocchio great pg parents now
streaming only on disney
[Music]
and
flash
i present to you
the eighth wonder of the world
[Music]
the one and only
[Applause]
hello pups
[Music]
[Music]
turn around let me get a look at you
i will be right here when you get back
pinocchio is running around loose
without a conscience can you imagine the
trouble he's gonna get into wouldn't
want that on my conscience everybody
who's anybody wants to be a somebody but
i want to be real why on earth would you
want to be real when you can be
famous
[Music]
nokia should have been home by now
you won't be a puppet anymore
that's for sure
[Music]
[Music]
truthful
not selfish
[Music]
you will always be my real boy
a lie can really change a person pinocks
oh what's happening jiminy looks like
some sort of fairy magic
kinda on the nose if you ask me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
starlight star bright
first star i see tonight
i wish i may
i wish i might
have the wish
i wish tonight
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you